they're good targets or mostly yeah
thank you very much appreciate the
opportunity to come and speak I'm a
little bit of an outsider to this
community coming from traditional
numerical linear algebra and I'ma
certainly an enthusiastic admirer of
rent and LA and I'll try to make a few
connections here throughout my my talk
and maybe entice you to look at a
problem or two that that maybe your
algorithms and skills can be
particularly helpful for for addressing
my motivation for talking on this
subject really comes from some
conversations with Petros in the past
about convergence theory for Krylov
subspace methods and some of the ways
these algorithms come to be used in
recent developments and in randon LA so
with that let me get a setting here
we're thinking of a a large square
sparse matrix protect potentially
non-hermitian and I have complex entries
there so we don't have to worry about
making any special exceptions for
complex eigenvalues and eigenvectors but
of course if you like to live in the
real world you're welcome to to do that
we're imagining that all eigenvalues of
a are too expensive to compute although
there are some settings in which we do
want all the eigenvalues of a for
example if we want some statistics about
the distribution of the spectrum some
problems in quantum mechanics so we're
looking for some small subset of the
spectrum let's say M eigenvalues and
often these are eigen values that are on
the right end of the spectrum or the
left end of the spectrum or largest in
magnitude and so forth so the technique
will use a variety of algorithms we
might apply to this but but many of them
fall in the framework of projection
methods which I guess you could say is a
kind of sketching where we're gonna look
at the operation of a on a subspace that
has very low dimension larger than the
number of eigenvalues were trying to
compute but smaller much smaller than
the ambient dimension and and so we hope
that we compress a down to this low
dimensional subspace and that some few
number of those eigenvalues of the
compression of a onto the subspace are
accurate approximations of the
eigenvalues of a so everything will then
come down to how we
that subspace the and so as I say mostly
this is the the deterministic case but I
will address a few Rand NLA issues as we
as we go along so I had a couple
questions yesterday do we even need to
care about non symmetric matrices why is
the non symmetric eigenvalue problem
relevant well of course if you're
interested in SVD calculations or many
problems from quantum mechanics the
symmetric case is fine but there are
many applications particularly coming
from a variety of different discrete or
continuous time dynamical systems where
we're very interested in computing the
eigenvalues of a non symmetric matrix
and and understanding some of the
spectral perturbation theory behind that
so a few examples for you here and one
plot just show you what the complex
plane looks like if you've not visited
there very often I encourage you to dip
your toes in we're looking for I ghen
values of a pretty small matrix of
dimension 380 1000 in serious
calculations for 3d fluid flows we might
be interested in a matrix that's a
thousand times as large so this is a
something of a toy problem even though
it's quite large and here I'm I'm
looking for I think I've computed 1600
eigenvalues in this example most of
which are a number of which are on the
screen there well I show you pseudo
spectra here that's what those colored
lines are all about so both we want both
so in this case the rightmost eigenvalue
is very stable to perturbations and it's
perfectly legitimate to compute it i
have no faith in the accuracy of these
eigenvalues but i don't care about them
so much i care about that right most one
for understanding a fluid stability
question okay so a overview of
projection based eigen solvers so that's
the setting we've had before
you see the power method is the simplest
version of this just just take powers of
a applied to a vector ax a
one-dimensional subspace easy to
implement but it can be slow of course
very little storage in this community of
course we've seen the great success of
subspace iteration powers of a now
applied not to a vector but to a block
of vectors where now we have larger
dimensional subspaces does
vector products can be very quick to
apply we build large subspaces quite
fast it also has the ability to get
repeated eigenvalues if we have
multiplicity but there's a richer world
out there of kriya of subspace methods
we're now instead of just looking at it
say one fixed power applied to veca
block effectors we're gonna look at the
aggregation of many different powers of
a which will give us the ability to work
in polynomials of a applied to X and if
you if you doubt the wisdom of Kriya of
methods you might just think you know if
you had the choice to say apply a to a
block of ten vectors so in other words
ten first iterations of the power method
versus looking at the first ten
iterations of the power method applied
to one vector you might expect that that
those by the time you get ten iteration
to the power method they're really
learning quite a lot about a dominant
eigenvalue much more than you would from
the aggregation of one iteration applied
to a bunch of different vectors so the
high powers matter a lot but that's lots
of applications of a block methods are
trying to get the best of both worlds
where will apply powers of a to blocks
of vectors and that's a technique
obviously that's popular in this
community particularly for SVD
calculations Joel was showing some nice
calculations with this yesterday to a
few of us
the trick is how do you benefit how do
you balance large subspace dimensions
with block sizes and trying to strike
the right balance to get fast
convergence but even within the single
vector Krylov world which i'll focus on
today there are lots of different
options that maybe this community hasn't
yet explored fully so for example I'll
say a few words about restarting Krylov
methods where after we've maybe done an
initial calculation we try to improve
the starting vector by running a
polynomial filter in a against the
starting vector to get faster
convergence by getting a better starting
vector an intriguing method that that
I'm pretty fond of at the moment is
where we take a polynomial
transformation of a and apply Kri law of
subspace based on that polynomial
transformation this is a way to get very
high powers of a I'll show you an
example or two of this
later so we can we can really get very
large powers of a this way or we can do
something even more radical like
transform a entirely turn the spectrum
inside out by inverting a or even taking
a rational transformation of a and these
are popular algorithms essential
algorithms in engineering computations
dicta the shift invert Krylov so when
you run eggs you're either running
restarted Krylov or you're running some
version of shift in berkeley law say for
sBBs okay a few preliminaries that will
help us with some of our convergence
theorems that follow
I'll assume I have some number of
distinct eigen values for each distinct
eigen value I can construct this complex
contour integral even if we have a
symmetric matrix we can still define
this contour integral around a little
contour that contains that single eigen
value and no others and it turns out
that that contour integral is actually a
projector and it's range is the
invariant subspace the the eigen space
and possibly some other stuff for non
symmetric a associated with the
eigenvalue if you have a symmetric
matrix and the eigenvalue has a simple
eigen unit eigen vector that's compound
or integral it's just the outer product
of the eigen vector with itself but in a
non symmetric case things can be a
little bit more interesting in
particular while PJ is a projector
there's no need that it be orthogonal in
other words it's not a symmetric
projector it's not a nice the norm of
the projector can be larger than one but
together these projectors give us a
resolution of the identity so I'll have
a little bit extra notation here PG will
be the sum of the projectors associated
with the eigenvalues i want you g g is
for good is for the invariant subspace
i'm trying to compute and m is the
number of well the dimension of the
invariant subspace the number of of
eigenvalues if you will counting
multiplicity and then the b is for for
bad we have the complimentary spectral
projector the complimentary invariant
subspace and then the remaining
dimension just have that notation down
in the way that we're going to measure
convergence is is not by looking at the
in an eigenvalue or even the the norm of
a residual if we put an approximate
eigen pair in and apply it to a we're
gonna measure angles between subspaces
it's very geometric way of looking at
the problem and so that's also we can
define the angle between two vectors of
course we're now defining the angle
between two subspaces this came up of
course in the last the last talk we're
doing lots of those calculations and the
plots that follow to just draw a
convergence curves many angle
calculations and this measure which we
call the containment gap is really a way
of assessing how M dimensional subspace
compares to a K dimensional subspace so
assuming K is larger than M so we have a
chance of approximating all the vectors
we're looking for the best approximation
to our M dimensional subspace from that
larger subspace so every place you see a
delta just think of its this the sine of
the angle between the best approximating
subspace and the invariant subspace now
in particular notice I'm not saying how
we're going to extract eigen values from
this subspace so that could be another
issue we'd have to have to think about
this is what typical convergence curves
look like in the non symmetric case
there's some warm-up period where the
the kree law of space just has to get
big enough to even approximate all K
vectors so there's a kind of plateau
there and then there can be a dip where
are some special properties of the
starting vector and the orientation of
the invariant subspace to its
complimentary subspace causes the kind
of dip of fast but slowing convergence
and then the method settles down into
some pretty steady linear convergence
rate and sometimes you'll see it dip
down faster at the end so this this this
curve will actually accelerate and we'll
talk about why that might happen so this
is the kind of thing we would like to
come up with an upper bound for and
along to the theory that I'll be
describing today goes back in its roots
to work Yusuf Saud did a couple of
beautiful 1980 papers a subsequent 1983
paper but a couple of papers that Chris
Beatty and I wrote with John Rossi and
Dan Sorensen ultimately we're gonna
bound convergence based on the product
of two constants which I will actually
tell you what those constants are
and then a polynomial approximation
problem we're trying to approximate one
by the product of a polynomial that's
fixed it has its roots the m eigen
values that I'm trying to compute times
another polynomial that I'm free to
choose of degree K minus two times M
remember I'm computing M eigen values so
now for this bound to hold I'm assuming
I've built my subspace out to at least
two M so that's already maybe a little
bit of a gap in the analysis here but it
turns out to work out that way we're
sampling by twice just to start getting
convergence exactly the angle the angle
between the subspace but I didn't tell
you how nice this problem is this is
it's very nice yeah
the examples that I'll show for
illustrative purposes are going to be
have nice gaps and eigen values and so
forth okay but I went back to the
problem I showed you were in an earlier
slide things are much more difficult for
for real problems like that but I want
to be able to just show you some nice
cartoons almost of what the convergence
looks like so you could scale this to
your problem out of zero or two there if
you like yeah
okay so what are the constants going to
be the first constant c1 will tell me
how my starting vector is oriented
toward the invariant subspace my second
constant will depend on the orientation
of the eigenvectors to one another and
I've told you about the polynomials will
have this set Omega B which is some set
that contains the the bad eigenvalues I
don't want to compute that's the set on
which the approximation problem is posed
and I've told you then about this
polynomial alpha kind of a minimum
polynomial for the desired eigenvalues
okay so so let's first of all I had a
caveat here that if the subspace was
reachable we have to obey some ground
rules which I'll go through quickly if
you don't have a component if your
starting vector lacks a component and
the eigenvector you're trying to compute
even if we just look at the power method
you get no action from the eigenvalue
lambda one that you're trying to compute
it doesn't show up it could be any value
you have no hope of computing that
particular direction that's true for non
hermitian so this I'm assuming I'm not
assuming a Jordan a Jordan block here
but yeah that decomposition holds in
general so you won't see the direction
you're not trying to compute but a
different problem arises if we have
multiple heigen vectors that are
linearly independent associated with the
same eigenvalue simplest case would be
an identity matrix where if we just try
to build the krilov subspace you run out
of gas after just one step and you
exactly recover the eigenvector we call
this happy breakdown but it may be if
you think of your eigen basis of the
identity as being columns of the
identity that vector X maybe doesn't
look like any of the vectors you are
trying to look for here's maybe a more
striking example - Jordan blocks a
two-by-two Jordan block in the left and
a 3x3 three on the bottom right and I
have a vector X here where I can choose
any component I want in that second slot
so in particular I might try to compute
the eigen vector zero one zero zero zero
by making this
starting vector lean really closely
toward that eigenvector and it turns out
that that regardless of see I'm actually
going to compute the eigen vector 0 0 0
0 1 and I get a 3x3 Jordan blocks so
even regardless of how closely oriented
that starting vector was to the 2x2
Jordan block I always get the other
Jordan block if you will this is one of
the the quirks of these Kriya operations
if I wanted to get the 2x2 Jordan block
I'd have to it's only a set of measure 0
starting vectors that can find it so we
have to be a little careful in the
presence of this multiplicity ok so I
think that's enough yeah exactly
yes so if I had the power building out a
basis of say suppose they just think of
this example right I think of just the
identity even that simple example with a
block of two vectors here I would run
out of gas after a two dimensional
subspace
yeah like the identity yeah yeah okay
let's think now assume we're in the and
in a case where we don't have some
unlucky starting vector we're gonna
actually be able to attain some
convergence how does this how does this
procedure go how does the starting
vector influence things so if I just
look at a single I could look for a
single eigenvalue this old bound from
sod which we can kind of express in this
way and and now the leading constant is
1 over the norm of the spectral
projector applied to the starting vector
in other words the component of the
starting vector in the eigenspace I'm
trying to compute and you can see as the
starting vector is oriented further and
further away from that space this
constant gets larger and larger and
larger we expect slower convergence and
for subspaces
again single vector iterations but now
looking for k4m eigenvalues we have
another kind of constant that looks
pretty similar that looks at the
orientation of the worst vector in our
Krylov space of dimension m the size
we're looking for and we find the vector
that has the best orientation toward the
bad subspace in the least orientation
toward the good subspace so it's a nice
way of seeing how what does this
constant c1 should be we can compute it
using a generalized singular value
decomposition and if we look at an
experiment where we take starting
vectors that are oriented with a
subspace of dimension 8 hermitian case
here of increasing angle so start very
very close our convergence curve is fast
as we get farther away we slow down
eventually get a plateau before we
converge and if we look at what the
error balance would be there this
constant c1 is shown as the black dot
and as it gets high 10 to the 6 that's a
scary constant but we see that that
gives us kind of the right height to our
convergence curve to capture this
rightmost blue convergence only to do
with the starting vector not so the
eigenvector
oh it bakes that in because these
spectral projectors measure the
conditioning of the eigenvectors yes
it's not it's this constant is is very
subtle in that way these are not
orthogonal projectors those are the
spectral projectors they're it's
unavoidable
it's unavoidable in the balance I go
ahead it's a feature and not a bug okay
what about the eigenvalues themselves
and we should probably look at this
quickly here this is I think sort of the
most boring part of the bounds
we need polynomials that are that are
that approximate a function well over
the unwanted part of the spectrum if
you're in the hermitian case you come up
with an interval that contains the
unwanted eigenvalues this is the the
famous gap condition that we've been
looking at before what's the separation
of lambda m from the rest of the
spectrum can use chebyshev polynomials
to get the convergence if you have an in
the complex plane you use potential
theory so if we have some unwanted
eigenvalues and some well separated nice
eigenvalues we bound the unwanted
eigenvalues by a continuous set we can
formally map it to the disk that causes
the wanted eigenvalues also to move to a
conformal map of the exterior of the
disk everything on the disk is nice we
know how to put interpolation points
that are give us optimal approximation
on that region if we're working on the
disk and then invert the conformal map
to go back to the domain we care about
and we know where to put optimal
interpolation points to interpolate that
function one over alpha to get a good
approximation so greens functions give
us some way of getting convergence rates
that linear rate that I showed you
earlier but if the convergence is slow
as often happens now think about whether
you're solving the right problem or not
here's an example if I have a just think
of a symmetric case again I want to
compute a single eigen value then the
convergence rate gets worse if I imagine
lambda 1 and lambda 2 being locked down
but as the dimension gets large and I
get more and more eigen value spread
further and further and
they're a part this is exactly the
situation that happens when we
discretize a differential operator an
unbounded differential operator and as
we get better and better discretization
lambda n gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and so the convergence rate slows
so here's an example just a
descritization bill applause Ian in 1d
256 pretty slow convergence that's 10 to
the minus 1 this is a example I could
use if you want you want big numbers we
could have big numbers yeah if I if I
improve the discretization of 5/12
convergence slows and it gets even worse
the better and better I I get those are
those are calculations and not not
bounds so the discretization is better
the convergence is worse we can see
what's going wrong if we go to the cria
of subspace method itself
what's that uniform discretization but
if I think that I'm really applying the
cria log method to an operator the
unbounded operator minus the second
derivative with DRS a boundary
conditions and I pick some vector that
satisfies those boundary conditions and
I try to generate Microlife subspace it
fails it the first step when I apply my
operator to F and usually I won't be in
the domain of the operator anymore so it
makes no sense to apply the operator
twice so the functional analysis is
saying this is the wrong way to solve
this problem well how do we do it well
we should invert the operator and if we
think of what what the inverse of the of
the laplacian is what's going to be a
compact operator back in high school I
learned about constants of integration
right and then if if we pick those
constants so that we stay in the domain
of the operator we're golden and now
look at the convergence this is in
Mathematica now there's no
discretization I can run length shows in
Mathematica and we get what we call
super linear convergence that we get
fast convergence rates and this is in
the eigen value error because we've
applied the operator to two we applied
the method to the right operator the
inverse and so if you're convergence is
slow because your eigenvalues are
bunched together maybe you want to do
something to turn the spectrum inside
out
so as we call shift invert or nolde
that's what I use does when you ask for
a smallest magnitude eigenvalues of a
non symmetric problem for example
another thing we can do a poor man
spectral transformation is is not to
invert a but to apply some polynomial in
a this is what we call polynomial
preconditioning we can use min res I had
to honor the method from Michael
Saunders in the in the front row here we
can use min res to construct the
polynomial pi that we want to use and
here's just an example where we have a
bunch of eigenvalues which you can read
across the horizontal axis that are
bunched together on the left part of the
spectrum maybe have a little bit of a
gap and then bunched together again down
here and as I look at different
polynomials of increasing degree I can
read the eigenvalues of pi of a off on
the left here through these grey lines
and what we see is that as the
polynomial degree increases i'm
separating out these eigenvalues here
they're much more separated on this axis
than they are on this axis and now I can
run the Krylov method on pi of a and
potentially get much faster convergence
okay what about eigenvectors well they
come into the bound through this
constant c2 and if you're only
interested in a symmetric case you're c2
is always equal to 1 and if you're
interested in non symmetric problems
then you need some way of handling that
departure from normality or the
departure form orthogonal t of the
eigenvectors and there are various
choices you can make for sets in the
complex plane on which to bound the norm
of f of a so the eigenvalues of a the
numerical range the epsilon pseudo
spectra so now we pose the approximation
problem on sets whose size grows but we
have better control over the constants
so we have a variety of different bounds
here that depend on that departure from
symmetry in the context of our bounds
this f of a is really f of a constrained
to the unwanted invariant subspace and
we just apply the bounds in that setting
the constant here for the numerical
range is conjectured to be 2
that's known as Cruz's conjecture and it
was had been eleven point oh eight for
many years until Cruz a and palencia
chiseled it down a little bit last year
okay this is I think a cute plot of how
the power method is affected by angles
between subspaces angles between
eigenvectors so i set up a little 3x3
matrix with two entries here alpha and
beta that i'll turn on in turn so if i
if i leave them both to zero i have a
symmetric problem and i run the power
method to compute the eigen vector u1
the dominant eigenvector and I see the
power method starts here and it bounces
around and it's converging just like I'd
expect but now if I turn on alpha and I
add some coupling between these two
eigenvectors welcome the power method
contrary to what we normally expect that
actually makes this Dirk common
direction you want and you two they're
almost aligned that makes that more
magnetic it reels all those power method
iterates in and so paradoxically a
departure from orthogonality can
sometimes improve your conversions
however if your if it's the other eigen
values that are that are coupled
together then you can get something
that's a little nastier and the
subordinate eigenvectors can be the the
magnets that slow down your power method
convergence so there's a lot of subtle
business in terms of angles between
eigenvectors that you don't get to enjoy
if you live only in the symmetric world
what I'd like to end on is talking about
really a crucial technology that makes
eggs work this idea of restarting and
it's also a humbling aspect of of the
problem from the non-symmetric
perspective suppose I have some matrix
complex matrix our matrix with complex
eigenvalues and I want to compute those
five rightmost eigenvalues here's how i
works we first compute some approximate
eigenvalues these black circles none of
which is a particularly good
approximation of any of the eigenvalues
but many on the periphery of the
spectrum as we expect from pre-loss
methods and what is is going to do is it
says I want five eigenvalues so I'll
just assume that the five right most of
these approximations are the best and
I'll use the
the other bad approximations as roots of
a polynomial that I'll used to filter
out my starting vector so I build this
polynomial it's magnitude is large in
the gray area and small in the the
lighter area so many of those unwanted
eigenvalues are now damped out by by
this polynomial that I apply to my
original starting vector and so to use
Himes language from the last talk if you
view you fix your dimension K and you do
a standard creel off method and
approximate eigen values you're doing a
kind of sketch and solve right and you
hope you get accurate eigen values I
would argue that this is a kind of
sketch to precondition approach you're
doing some compression of a you're
learning about a you're then using that
to starting iteration that will filter
repeatedly because of course now you've
got a better starting vector and and and
once you're addicted to that you've got
to keep going until you drive the
convergence down now weird things can
happen you can make it fail for non
symmetric case cases and the symmetric
case we have interlacing and that's
crucial to so many convergence bounds
for hey I can solvers for the hermitian
case there's symmetric case so what that
says is that the iteration gets larger
iteration count increases we approximate
the eigenvalues the red lines here from
the inside out and the eigenvalues can
never bunch up the approximate
eigenvalues can never bunch up in the
ends of the domain in the non symmetric
case all bets are off there's no sense
that the eigenvalues will that they're
even that are even real
well the eigenvalues could be real but
these approximate eigenvalues could be
complex they can be outside in the
bounds of the extrema of the spectrum
they can bunch up in weird ways all
sorts of nightmare scenarios here's the
worst of all the eigenvalues of a are
just these numbers here read from left
to right
here's K equals one two three four five
six seven you can make monsters like
this all day long using a beautiful
construction from your even do note
Eben's and wrong so life can be bad but
usually it's not
because of a new poultry part was huge
yeah yeah you could see there's
something hidden here in that last
column right nothing looks bad until you
see see that okay so I'm running out of
time
I just want to introduce you to a cool
set of problems here in the last few
slides suppose I want to just this is my
R and NL a component of the talk I take
a 3 by 3 Jordan block and I'm going to
compute to approximate eigen values now
obviously the eigen values are 0 there's
no sense of what interlacing would be if
the eigen values are only zero but I
know that the approximate eigen values
must always fall in this set called the
numerical range which in this case
conveniently enough is just a disc and
so those are two discs I'm going to do
an experiment where I compute I think
10,000 approximate eigen values for the
left and right so 10,000 complex
subspaces every time I do an experiment
with one of these two-dimensional
subspaces I'll sort the left
approximation and the right
approximation to zero and I'll see if
there's any pattern and sure enough what
you see is that the left approximation
always falls in this kidney shape and
the right and it's mirror image and
indeed you can draw a line and you can
prove using a trace argument from
Russell Carden that you can never get a
ritz value to the left of this line or
right of this line so in particular I'll
skip these examples where two matrices
with the three matrices with the same
numerical range but very different
approximate eigen values maybe here's
the bound to say that there's a kind of
interlacing that you looking at I gain
values of the hermitian part of a that
allows you to get some strips in the
complex plane where your different
approximate eigen values have to fall so
it's not as strong as we would like but
it's at least some movement toward an
interlacing theorem in the non symmetric
case it holds for singular values as
well maybe just some closing thoughts
polynomials are better than powers we
really benefit from Krylov methods as
opposed to just subspace methods with
that just keep one power of a
block methods hold additional promises
beyond even what I've shown here and get
large subspaces quickly but you have to
find some way to maintain linear
independence and handle some of those
numerical considerations restarting
makes these engineering computations
work and if there's a way they're harder
to analyze but I think that's the the
secret technology that could could help
with some of these tricky data science
problems shift invert you can see what
it can do to a problem take something
that converges glacially and turn it
into something that converges super
linearly if you understand something
about where your problem comes from
finally not her recent problems matter
they're solved every day particularly
for interest in dynamical systems and
even though I've sort of caused question
about the the theory here is an AR PAC
worked remarkably well in these problems
the fact that the technologies you know
twenty twenty some years old now and
still in use is is really a testament to
its effectiveness
and I'd love for random matrix theory to
tell me something about the eigenvalues
of these compressions in the non
symmetric case you have any ideas I'm
all yours
thank ya that's the trick right so there
are things called inexact methods that
might then use a kree law of subspace
linear solver like like min res to apply
the inverse operator and do it exactly
then the question is to what tolerance
need it be need to be applied so now you
think you're kind of only Fuzzle e
applying your operator in this case and
Valerius even seen e and Daniel shield
have a nice Siam review paper I think
God on this on this topic
looking at accuracy of an exact creel
off methods
is that a real restarting Bertrand you
can imagine how to how to do that yeah
yeah yeah I don't it's not an AR pack
for example what's that I think a bit
I'd have to I'd have to think through a
little bit of this painting and
recycling try no spaces that people
don't throw that is tickle America
scientists yeah so so recycling is you
know you have a mult series of problems
to solve and you have a good cry loft
space and you'd like to sort of build on
that wisdom even in sods 1980 paper he
says basically he has an explicit
restarting scheme where he says this is
basically like blah clang shows
any comments on the feast on the feast
method well when I said mostly we use
subspace projection feast methods are
contour integral ideas that that are
pretty interesting you get a huncle
matrix approximation of your compression
of your of your matrix certainly
something circulation and I and our form
master student Michael Brennan are very
interested in in the case of nonlinear
eigenvalue problems some really
beautiful ties to system realization
theory they're yeah any class of methods
[Applause]